yeah hello and welcome to this video
yeah what did i do there somehow the
recording was a little bit strange at
the beginning so anyway transposed to a
Sicilian and see if he has something in
store there sometimes people play Knight
f3 c5 and they don't have a good recipe
there so let's see what he plays against
this strange mind with night every 23
but it is quite interesting yeah this
ending is a little bit better for white
really I have to remember however how it
is played I keep forgetting it I think
is it night a4 in this position I think
it's night a 4 right here yeah yeah it's
not matter voice ok now they go b8 or
rook b8 yeah I'm threatening that b6 so
um and now what is the what is the deal
of Bishop f4 there is Ruby form that
doesn't work so I think you take and
then play Bishop f4 and before this b3
yeah yeah I'm getting them I'm getting
them I think this is correct
hmm I'm not so sure about Bishop f4
actually but ok let's do it root before
I go B 3 and later C form this ending is
supposed to be a bit better for white
due to blacks defects in the pawn
structure a6 in particular is weaker SH
and white some pieces are also more
active note that I have the rook
developed on h1 or
so I can do something in some cases at
least like with rook h4 h5 there are
some sometimes possibilities like that
yeah I'm wondering but no and Bishop d7
I'll just take a 6 I just take a 6s
thought why wouldn't that work if he
takes there I just forget I can take
that he cannot take twice due to Bishop
b5 at the end I think this is just a
pawn what is his plan I mean I get
Bishop b5 in shortly and that is a
strong pawn a form the bishop on b5 when
the pawned work well together MMSE trine
what is he trying here Ruby for check or
something such any dangerous don't
really seem our black looks more or less
busted him
probably should just develop your knight
f6 or so and then just find maybe if you
can try a knight f6 f or c3 like
activate the night there I mean I've got
some weak squares yeah this is some move
that can be played but it might weaken
even more okay so if I take it yes
rookie four that's no good
probably to detune yeah I mean he can't
shake me only four but I don't know if
that really does all that much I just
play King u1 I guess okay um well yeah I
can play Bishop c3 and take you five huh
what shall I just covered this I could
cover it a funny line it would be an
hour long castle through k2 which
forgets it's kind of it's very very
strange idea okay so I'm checking first
don't have to but I think it's okay to
do so and now can i trap his rook this
is really something that interests me if
I can trap his rook King D one would
threaten Bishop c3 it doesn't have many
squares exactly and I can always play
Bishop c3 and Tiki five which is
absolutely good for me but I still want
to try to trap his rook him a kingdom
one threatens King and almost King c1
it's not a threat
yeah I wonder just bishops III I'm
taking a bit too long here you might
have bishop before as well okay I mean
this is probably just strong m44 trying
to trap the rook a3 king c1 what is so
dizzy doing against a tonight f6 maybe
Bishop c1 is not a threat a threatened
Bishop c3 as well though this is the
main threat and even after Knight f6
Bishop c3 that would work 94 takes and
piece up at the end I don't really see a
move here for him if he goes Bishop
before I go Bishop c1 and it is trapped
my looks that looks pretty pretty busted
deform a meum and then I mean came at I
can't even I can't even do that Bishop
see one look before Bishop a3 rook takes
b5 Bishop takes a fade as a complete win
[Music]
that's a that's a cute line actually
with the rook hanging ng7 hanging so I
think this can be done let's play it you
might get it on the board or is he just
giving up the exchange now with Bishop
III no and now Bishop a4 the only move
that makes any sense then his rook takes
b5 unless he wants to give the exchange
and then I take a fade and then the rook
on b5 hangs and g7 hangs with the winner
of the rook in the corner so this is a
neat line that I talked about like a
minute ago and it actually happens to to
pop up on the board yeah now his both
rooks are essentially hanging a b5 and
g7 hangs with the trap on a Jade no
moves
black resigns yeah no moose let's check
it yeah this is an interesting variation
the Queen d3 is a really strange looking
move but there doesn't seem to be
anything great against it I mean black
is obvious they're not going to lose
perforce after such a move but it is
absolutely playable a6 played and now
this idea comes into play with Queen g3
yeah it's difficult for black not to
trade now I can try something like that
but after simple developing moves like
Bishop d3 for example it's always tricky
for him to develop because the g7 pawn
is constantly attacked so you cannot
move the f8 bishop and why don't a
castle f4 this kind of thing I mean it's
a bit better for white in the trade now
yeah it's not easy after d5 this move is
is this interesting and I'd a for it
makes this basically impossible and I
can go here and then grab this with a
fantastic ending so this is making quite
some sense I don't think it is the only
more think there's also something else
that they try what was it yeah I think
the computer but should be 7 I think
this also has been seen but rook b8
though and now I think taking and Bishop
f4 is correct this is this yeah and now
black have some other options I think
what the engine is giving 85 has been
tried and this is probably not working
at all I can really just take it and
this is a very important pawn to a6 pawn
you Jim after that it's I think it's
definitely lost after Bishop a4 I mean
in other cases you are porn down with
black but at least White's position is
somewhat uncoordinated in here yeah you
cannot grab a foyer okay you're
basically basically stuck now and after
this I think the roof is definitely
trapped the King he won is strongest
yeah I was also looking at this but
this is much better
but King Dhawan is it's probably winning
as the engine confirms and trapping the
trapping of the rook simply a three I
can play a three I didn't think about
that
I saw that one a little bit before
because I found this idea very
attractive but yeah the engine is of
course right here here you can basically
play with this an exchange down this is
actually it's still not super easy to
convert in a blitz game because White's
pawns are kind of worthless the
structure he has kind of worthless you
have the apron which is not worthless
but you know it's not very well
organized and he's got some stuff here
c3 yeah Knight could come in and so on
and so some tricks around
therefore I understand that the engine
is giving this move here which it's a
simple move really which forces like to
take and now my pawn structure is just
repaired you have got two connected
passes just a much better good man I was
so attracted towards this that I that I
didn't really think of anything else now
as a double attack on both rooks
basically because after I grab C cell g7
the rook on h8 will fall yeah an
interesting game if you're looking for a
line against the chairman of here's
warning thanks for watching I forgot to
switch on the view